all right guys i have a lot of dates
coming up i have a one-nighter
in at the brea improv on 5
27 so that's may 27th that was hard i
had to count the whole calendar
but check it out the link should be live
now so just google it i'll post it on my
socials too i will be doing hartford
funny bone
in connecticut on the 27th to the 29th
of august
come see me it's gonna be so fun it's
already been so fun to be back on stage
i can't wait to
meet all my slugs
wait can we actually talk about how your
eye looks like she's like
how is that possible lester i don't know
she's 92
yeah my aunt is 92 she came to my
stand-up show and she
i was shocked is your mom in her 70s or
something no my mom's in her 60s though
the women
on my mom's side of the family are just
like
they're a little hoes like they look
good they always got a man
like my aunt like over and over again
the husband will die and then they got a
new boyfriend in their 70s like they are
just
they just like are shining bright and
people like them i don't have those
qualities
uh by the way my dad i was talking to
when he was like yeah maybe your mom
will have a
boyfriend again one day i'm like what
he's saying some dark [ __ ] to me where
i'm like
wait i absolutely annie like i don't
happen
are we not what are we not jumping onto
a new set of pelvis
sometimes i'm like no i'm done after
this but then
ultimately if there is someone out there
you know i have that thought at 32 years
old is so to have what thought
that you're thinking about the the the
person you're going to date in your
nursing home
is so the name esther
esther i think you would kill it in a
nursing home right now
you would be in a nursing home um uh
floozy
i picture myself more like neglected at
home
than a nursing home i feel like people
just forgot i was there
and then i'm just like watching movies
alone it's just you're nursing
yourself to sleep at home
there's like 13 dogs around me i don't
know
dude i'm going to be [ __ ] ski like
[ __ ]
no no no no no i'm going to be throwing
blue chewing everyone's things and just
exactly everyone very boring statistic
but there's actually a
staggering rise of sdds in that
demographic i love it older people
because it's floofy central floofy
it's floofy time i thought she was
saying flu season i'm gonna i'm gonna
um come out of retirement when i'm back
in the retirement home i'm gonna come
out of retirement at the retirement home
and i'm back to skiing just
yes dude i'm going out in style i'm
going to be in a wheelchair just like
with i'll pop my teeth out i was like
moving around
i'm going to be so i'm going to be sewn
up i'm going to get every my mouth and
my
genie and my butt sewn up well hopefully
you're placed in our nursing home and
we'll walk pop pop
pop pop pop scissors for that
we're going to pop you back open that's
there see i just i want to like
go out and style you know get like have
the last great sex and when i'm young
and beautiful
and then i'll just close up shops so you
already did your great job
so you're done okay good i'm retired wow
[Music]
i started crying the other day because
what a sentence
todd uh todd is 11 years younger than me
as we know
and the other day and he's promised to
die after he's like i promise to die
after you i'm like thank god
so he's going to kill you i would rather
that be the way out than it
him fail me and his promise because he
goes the other day he's like i think i'm
going to get a motorcycle and i just
started crying i'm gonna pms they might
start crying like you're gonna be
[ __ ] dead before me [ __ ] promised
like todd doesn't you know he doesn't go
to sleep before me he makes sure i'm
asleep first oh i cannot be with anyone
who sleeps before me it's it's a deal
breaker for me
i totally agree sadly i need someone
hovering and making sure
that everything is peaceful
and safe and i hear little footsteps
around me it brings me peace
if bobby goes to sleep ahead of me it's
a huge fight the next morning oh i'm so
stressed out going to sleep
oh i'll wake the [ __ ] up
i do we actually have a problem in our
relationship
that's very consistent that is i wake up
with so much energy
and so loud and he has stayed up so much
later than me so he's really tired
and some days i will just like start a
loud conversation he's like ah
and like later that day he'll be like so
we need to talk about what you did this
morning
that why did you do that i'd have a
problem with that too
i'm on dave's side on this no dave's
right but i just have to say
todd i've trained todd to just he just
lays
and allows me to facetime next to his
sleeping head and i'll go look at the
sleeping asian like i'll sh i'll be like
say hi todd
you get away with so much because his
mom's so [ __ ] annoying i'm telling
you i get it now it's like he was
bred for me i'm very intolerant of very
early morning
loud noises and i don't even drink
coffee i'm not somebody who was like
talk to me when i've had my coffee i
just
i'm a slow starter i need to roll around
bed
relax stretch yeah you know ponder life
i can't just have that energy sprung on
me oh i
spring up like you thought i was dead
and someone gave me that epipen like
[ __ ]
uma thurman i'm like i just go so hard
my nose is bleeding
i go nuts i'm out and i'm just like what
can i do before randy notices them
up because i gotta take a piss do you
have that too
like tippy i'm like i will wake todd up
i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] but randy
will ruin my morning
yeah sometimes i try not to let like
sometimes donut wants to be lazy
and just stay with daddy but some
morning she needs to get up too
i just i'm like i gotta pee first
because i want i've been doing this is
so pathetic
but i have no habit of doing exercise
like
the habit's so far gone that i'm just
like all right [ __ ]
just after you brush your teeth just do
like 10 sit-ups 10 push-ups
and 10 squats and then just like do this
for 30 days and
you'll you can move forward that's
actually smart because you got
you got to start small you got to start
small
you start with her you go to me then you
go to her i'm doing height obviously
not wait but um
yeah no because i really because what
i'll do is i'll be like all right yeah
i'm back in the gym let's go baby and
it's like i'm like a heroin addict
that's like
give me all the heroin again and then
it's like you know they die
what you just have never met someone
that's ever done drugs so
have you ever had a friend esther who's
you know
sadly yes chronically like a drug addict
yes
sadly even esther that's how bad the
drug epidemic is really bad
yeah well theater majors are sometimes
kaku too
really you don't think so well not drug
i mean not you guys have too much to
live for the stage
i used to make so much i was such a
theater major bully when i was in
really college oh my god i had no clue i
didn't
realize that like oh like every famous
person that i watch in movies was like a
theater major
i didn't make that connection so i was
always like oh i just couldn't but every
party i'd go to with you guys
it's everyone just there's always a
piano that comes yeah gets rolled out
i'm like there was no [ __ ] piano when
i walked into this place
and then someone someone's lounging on
top it's like the connie chung situation
some junk [ __ ] falls off so
it's just i just assume everyone that
lives in la
who isn't from here is uh a full
blast cockhead that's just cokehead yeah
why do you assume that just everyone
from
every um sect of life
like ceos or someone who's a techie
george kimmel
my [ __ ] you know someone who's like
my bible thumping friend
they all do cocaine no how do they like
to me coke was like
in the 80s and then now we all know it's
bad for us and we don't do it
so what do you think is uh like flakka
is is what's hot right now
i don't know what flakka is but can i
just tell you esther
if esther doesn't like it's not in her
orbit she thinks everyone stopped doing
it
on esther club esther once had a thing
with carlos where they were like talking
about
foods that were 90s and they said tuna
fish sandwiches were 90s
we didn't say that it was exactly
jennifer's we said fettuccine alfredo
we said like like my mind is blanking
i forgot the key word it was 90s what
did we
eat in the 90s anymore george can you
pull up a video of someone on flaka
flakka is like kind of like i think it's
like a variation of like bath salts
so people look demonic so you know how
like with heroin it's like a turn down
methods that turn up this is like
stratosphere level like people are
eating
people is that a boy stabbing themselves
[Applause]
if i saw that in the middle of the
street i wouldn't even think drugs i
would just think straight demonic
possession
i would think performance art she's like
there must have been a theater major i
would go up and start bullying them he's
doing a monologue would you give money
give money you know like they do like
the someone who's performing by the
subway
they have their little guitar case out
you give money bust it bus
you know i don't busking musking i don't
do i don't have cash anymore
do you guys use cash were you giving a
lot of money out before
yeah no but i really don't like that's i
always feel bad about that because i
literally like i don't like ever since
kovid
i'm like it's just another germy thing
yeah
do people i'm curious did pete did
everyone else stop using cash i still
use cash because i
like if i travel like i have to tip in
cash and also i can't just have them
bend over and swipe
you know what i mean so that outfit you
need cash
[ __ ] i'm rolling with some hundreds
with that outfit
see i feel like we have not yet
acknowledged that this is the
island theme your outfit still hasn't
either
i know i look like a fat man at an
oyster bar no you look like
[ __ ] bernie from waking up bernie's
you look like her
what do we have george oh my gosh
kimball trip
hunter almost got a leg paper cut
and boy would i love to see that blood
squirt he's bleeding from his shins guys
from l l hawaiian thank you what is that
are you gonna try
i guess i have to it's in wait we can
give you gross things if they're in
sushi shape right
is it cooked yeah it's bad it is cooked
okay oh i'm so excited to eat them i'm
very excited that i get to break my
vegetarian habits on this show
i'm glad to drag your ass down too will
you tell me what's in spam
what are your restrictions and i'll tell
you if you can't have it meat wise scary
stuff
no it's spam is mostly pork oh i
i know that's why i was gonna say she's
she's she's jewish
well it's not that i just really don't
like eating pork
a lot of people don't like spam master
you're actually in good company also my
sister-in-law let me tell you this
i just i just haven't had pork in like
six years
but it doesn't look like they are
normally you eat it or not honestly me
neither
nobody wants like nobody cares i don't
know if i'm feeling high but i really
haven't had pork in years
this is giving me some kind of thrill
that i i didn't
know could happen is it delicious it's
really good i like that they were so
sure that esther was gonna eat it that
they got like a catering size there's
like a 10 of
100 of them george do you like it oh of
course
really 40 dollars worth and i think
we're about through uh 75
oh my god is this a mukbang do i have to
eat all of them okay fine
that's cool though that it's like sushi
i guess i'll just sit here we're almost
done
i'm an extremely fast eater me too
we're all pigs i know i was reading our
reviews just to kind of remember how
great we are and um
all the bad ones are like disgusting
eating noises
there's like three bad ones by the way
but they're all like disgusting
beware beware and so beware but that's a
real thing yeah
yeah that's true because we had a guest
he's um
he's from the band pixies and he's
bobby's friend um
and it drives him crazy he doesn't want
to be driven crazy because he wants to
be able to eat with his
family and whatnot but it just drives
him crazy the sound of eating
i will say no i know so i know i'm the
worst offender of it
i know someone that like had something
traumatic happen to them and the person
was chewing gum when they
wouldn't and so like this person now has
that
were you saying you didn't make them no
okay so we should probably we did
announce that this was a special
island episode um inspired by our
desire to go to hawaii hawaii right now
right now right now um annie is i really
like your outfit
thank you so much she came in full grass
skirt slides that's such an island thing
to wear
yeah and i'm and the feet are looking
gorgeous you'll never know but they look
great
i want to know um what your experiences
are
you have you ever have you ever been on
an island esther
uh i you know my tropical
emotional place i went to hawaii when i
was really little a couple times but i
don't remember it
so no not really what's the last warm
tropical humid place i know chicago gets
pretty humid in the summer but besides
the midwest
um in college my parents took me to
mexico once
that counts do they try to leave you
there they're trying to sell you
i'm not a big vacationer so like in my
adult life i've never done that but
actually and then once um in high school
my dance teacher got a job on a cruise
ship
so a few of us went on the cruise to
like support her
baby and one of the girls from my dance
studio was really rich
and so we all flew to florida and then
um we all got on the cruise and then
like
a few hours later there was a note from
the really rich girl and her mom that
said like
the quarters were too close for us and
they flew back home because
they thought the cruise was a dump oh my
god i mean cruises they
yeah they're all dumped well cruises
come back it seems like nobody remembers
when i say something my friend made the
smartest investment with her money
when carnival cruises took a big
trashing
because everyone's like cruises are dead
she just doubled down
yeah all their money there and they're
coming surprisingly they're coming back
listen people i don't know how people
love malls and they love water so you
put that mall in the water
people are there they be shopping i know
i
thought oh my god cruises are over
forever and now i'm like i would go on
one
that's right we should actually go on a
question i'll have a panic attack
it is the worst experience not even like
an elvis cruise i
cannot do cruises i cannot i will not i
refuse you'll have to drag me
tell us why um i just don't like like i
love boats
my grew up with boats i don't like being
stuck
in places with people that i haven't
that are i don't relate to
and who are unlikely swimmers but who
choose to put themselves in the middle
of [ __ ] ocean anyways
to eat for a whole [ __ ] week like
that's my nightmare
my friend graham kay is he's a really
funny comedian from canada
he um his parents booked a cruise
before the pandemic and they didn't
realize it was a spring break cruise so
they were just these two
like older people that wanted to go on a
vacation
just like kids like tits out like jager
everywhere it's like the funniest thing
i've ever seen
what about you guys what's your island
experience i grew up in the islands
oh so that's all i know i grew up in an
archipelago with seven thousand islands
so
my whole childhood is just island
hopping island hopping
did you have like a lot of tourists
around you what we hate the most
i mean our our economy relies on it
but just you know like when you come
from a country that is
highly touristy you start to build a
resentment
um because they they trash your homeland
yeah you know and they write on the
coral they [ __ ] up the reef they don't
they just they don't have no respect for
it they don't even have respect for the
people you know yeah
well what we see here is not very
respectable
so i'm very very um i have uh
many bones to pick with with tourists
yeah especially when i go back home i'm
like
you [ __ ] man like you can't
take them anywhere like some people
really just are um mindless
with the way they act when they're in a
different country and do you remember
americans being the worst
no i think if you guys ever come with me
to the philippines you're like [ __ ] like
or i don't know what kind of vacation
i'm going to do i'm going to carry
myself
i'm going to carry myself i don't think
you have a karen in you
i don't think i have a karen in me quite
often
i have a karen that's about this big and
when you add period blood to her
she's like one of those little those
little spongy [ __ ]
what are you gross
you guys i can't stop eating magic spoon
it tastes
so good growing up cereal was one of the
best parts of being a kid you guys agree
yeah just just fisting stuffing my face
watching cartoons
oh shoving your hands straight in but
why did we have to give that up why did
we have to give up because
it's full of junk and it's not good for
you and it's full of sugar it's just bad
enter magic spoon it has zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and only
four net grams of carbs in each serving
it's only 140 calories a serving and
it's keto friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy free low-carb and gmo
free and you can purchase a variety pack
which has four flavors that are
cocoa fruity frosted and peanut butter
and pro tip
if you combine the cocoa into peanut
butter you have a peanut butter cup and
i honestly have it for dinner
it's to me it's much better as a dinner
go to magicspoon.com
bathgirls to grab a variety pack and try
it today and be sure to use our promo
code bathgirls to check out to save five
dollars off of your order and magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money
no questions asked remember get your
next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at magicspoon.com bathgirls and
use the code bathgirls to save five
dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode you guys
we love neutral do you guys know that
30 million women are impacted by weekend
or thinning hair
if you're among them know that you're
not alone and that there's a solution
you can trust to deliver results
yeah and guys if you think i have full
hair these are extensions and you've
seen the tracks we know you've seen the
tracks
thousands of women have taken back
control of their hair with nutrifoal
with many users raving that the
supplement not only transformed their
hair but restored their confidence too
neutrophil offers two targeted formulas
for women that are clinically shown to
improve hair growth and thickness
with less shedding through all stages of
life i know for me
it was a very big insecurity when i got
off birth control pills and my hair just
started
falling out of my head and if it wasn't
for neutrophil
i'd still be in that very very sad place
but thankfully
these precious beautiful locks of mine
have been restored
and that's thanks to neutrophil do you
know what's funny is i ordered it for
dave
because they have it for men too and i
thought i was like oh he's gonna be like
upset and he was so happy to receive it
he was
excited you can grow thicker healthier
hair and support our show by going to
nutrafull.com and entering the promo
code bloodbath to save 20 off your first
month subscription
this is the best offer anywhere you guys
and it is only available to us customers
for a limited time
plus free shipping on every order get 20
off at nutrafl.com spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com
promo code bloodbath
what are you guys carings about like
what's the one thing that could happen
at any moment i
i it really it's something the wind
blows and
i will tell you mine it's it's it's when
i see someone else not
like i when i see someone else get [ __ ]
on
because i know how hard it is to speak
up for yourself when you're in that
situation
and especially in a work environment
i when i see someone like be left out of
something that i don't think they should
be left out of
i get really really pissed off and like
i you know what it is it's like we're in
a situation where maybe someone would
really
focus on being really polite i really am
so [ __ ] direct
i just turn into really really direct
and communicative
because i don't like seeing people and
because in my family my mom and my
sister
are those people that never stand up for
themselves and so i just feel
like and i'm such a loudmouth little
[ __ ] like
at least i was when i was little i'm not
anymore
she's also still little so you can take
that as you want
but yeah and then also like i don't know
i'm trying to think of other karen
things
i'll give you a caring of my own okay so
i'm
going to this pre pandemic i'm going to
see my nieces i only have like two days
with them okay
my phone something happens with my phone
where it's broken so we have to go to
the mall
everyone's working it's a very tight
schedule so
the only time my brother can take me to
the mall is during the day when the
girls are
like can't come for some reason so i
don't get to spend time with them so we
go to the mall
we go to the apple store i am wearing my
own merch um
luckily this is when i knew i wasn't
famous and i was very happy i wasn't
and so i bring in i bring my phone to
them
they go oh you just have to do a factory
reset that's all that's wrong with it
and i go why already did that and they
go
no you just have to do it like this and
i go are you sure
and they go yep that's it and i go okay
and then we leave and it immediately
shuts off again
and i have like work and stuff like i
can't not have my phone so now
i'm [ __ ] so now i have to we go home
my brother has to drop me off i have to
then get an uber to go back
i'm [ __ ] livid at that point because
i said to them like this is
very important you get it right they
promise it was just like you lazy piece
of [ __ ]
didn't want to go get the [ __ ]
whatever the
the geek guys are called at the apples
genius the geniuses
it's like you didn't want to get a
[ __ ] genius you were being [ __ ]
lazy
and you just [ __ ] my time with my
niece that's how i felt like if i feel
like there's like that type of thing and
i was pissed and they were just being so
difficult but they ended up
giving me like a new phone with for only
like 150
or something when it was supposed to be
200 but it was like it was a fight where
i was like you guys
[ __ ] me like this is on you and your
employee and i was more than willing to
be here and figure out what was wrong
with it
and you guys sent my ass back even when
i second guessed it
so i was pissed about that i mean i
could always trace it back i guess to
being my fault because i should have
just known they were full of [ __ ]
that it's just someone working at the
[ __ ] mall that doesn't give a [ __ ]
but
but i think that the apple store is a i
it's a great place for a meltdown i see
meltdowns all the time because it's like
it's a long wait
you're frustrated you can't communicate
with who you want to communicate with
because
my best friend who's a really patient
person like she she was just screaming
at me right now she's like actually a
funny apple store
it's always that every sentence where
someone rages out is always i was at the
apple store
because everything looks so sleek and
clean so it should just happen easily
and it never happens easily and they're
very smug
too the people that work at the apple
store they're always like we have a new
product like you ain't we [ __ ] okay
you're making [ __ ] minimum [ __ ]
wage i don't think you get a discount on
your [ __ ] apple watch
i know you paid full price and that's a
[ __ ] third generation so you're a
[ __ ] loser
i think they do get twenty percent
because i had a friend who was [ __ ]
an
apple store employee oh i do know how to
get people down
hang on we share this friend when we
were all trying to use the discount
before she cut it off she must have been
real hot
another time i cared it is always when
i'm visiting my niece too it is always
my
sister-in-law's i get more amped up too
when i'm around my family i i feel like
the protector or something
like everything has to be right like
don't [ __ ] with us like oh
if it's to defend someone in my family
yeah when my dad came to new york to
visit me he had just had like
it was he was recently recovered from
open heart surgery so it had been like
six months but he was still like pretty
weak
when we were on the subway and anyone
bumped it i was [ __ ] like
knocking people in the face like get the
[ __ ] away from my dad like just so mad
but that felt good
i like doing that i have that i don't
feel like that's being a karen
i think it's being a good member of
society because if anyone [ __ ] with my
family like god
god save them yes god protect your
[ __ ] souls
my brother too when we were like my twin
when we were in high school or in middle
school
and people would [ __ ] with him because
he was a lot smaller than me i would
just
i was like the biggest girl in the
middle school i was they called me the
jolly green giant because i wore my
dad's like army jacket and i was like
a foot taller than everyone i was this
height
and i just when i started smoking
cigarettes young this is me stunted
i would take their book bags and i would
slam them into lockers like my brother
would like be crying
and he was so humiliated by me doing
that
[Laughter]
was the flip mode have you guys ever
heard of like the flip mode squad
no what's that well it's like this thing
that kids did in high school where if
you weren't looking
they would flip your back by backpack
inside out they would put all your books
back
so when the bell rings and you're trying
to put your backpack on you didn't have
the arms
for it and everyone would just point and
laugh so if you got got by the flip mode
squad like it was humiliating
god saved the person that tried to do
that to esther god
they are imprisoned still if that
happened esther
they did not make it out of juvenile
jail i do not handle pranks well
surprises pranks i just i don't like
being
[ __ ] with at all i have my things
touched
like i just i mean annie knows we have
like we talked about that in the first
episode but when there was like a
surprise incident
which is so [ __ ] up that the mutual
friend did that because i didn't know
you didn't like [ __ ] surprise why
would i know like i mean i guess it's
like a shitty thing but he was like
she's gonna think it's so funny like
that was a direct sabotage
yeah i got thrown in a bush in high
school by a boy named pookie who had i
had a really big crush on and he was
fully cross-eyed i'm about to throw you
in a bush for the only fans
why did he throw you in a bush um i
think that he
was a had a crush he's a kind of a crack
baby
like he just was on he was not well in
the head and he was like on drugs for
sure but he was the only other white boy
in our school and when i first came from
to america i was like
ah that's what i see on tv yeah i know
he was cross side i was willing to just
be with whatever white boy was available
really
you know like you revere whiteness when
you first come here you thought he was
like checking you out but he wasn't he
wasn't
he was just cross-eyed and then he went
in for a hug but i didn't know it was
like a prank hug because as soon as i
came in he there was like a
over the fence which is a tiny little
bush and he threw me in a bush
and then um that's what he did to girls
not just me but a lot of people maybe he
was just trying to dip you but he was
like he threw my ass in the bush sounds
like he was
in love gay he didn't want
to touch you you know but he went he he
just thought it was funny to throw
people in bushes
because he was so strong wait he went in
for or was it like
you wanted to hug him he was disgusted
he probably sweaty pits he was like
and then he ducked and you fell into the
bush we had health class together we
were friends and i just thought that i
was
i was very enamored and i thought that
he i was going to get my first
solid hug from my crush and that was not
the case guys
speaking i had wait can i just say
speaking of health class can you stand
up and show us the pants that you're
definitely gonna get your period in
it's so epic i got a lot of makeup on it
but
look at this i'm wearing girls we're
going to get a lot of
bobby's a lucky guy
turn around no we're not turning around
guys i've seen it
and you're missing out kalylah don't
feel too bad i also
had an incident in middle school where
there was a cool guy
that i liked and we were aiming after
school
and we lived like somewhat close like he
lived right we
like there was a park right by his house
it was kind of close that you used to
park it
and watch it and he and he was like oh
i'll meet you there at like four o'clock
oh you never know it's so upsetting
people do that i know it was so
and i think that it's really stayed with
me because i'm
really afraid of like friends and like
people like that like not showing up
or just leaving i want to find this guy
and
kill him he has ruined a lot of my life
really made things difficult for me he
is probably in jail he was not he was
kind of a tough boy
a little bit older like teenage boys
were just really different or teenage
courtship was really different here so
when i first came here
i thought that you had to do like you
had to write letters to boys like i
didn't play
them in the shower were you bringing in
like shells you're like i got you this
i remember writing this boy benny carry
on
um a valentine's day letter and i was
like you have my heart and i don't want
it back
something like that and after after
chemistry class he was walking ahead of
me
and i was like penny penny i got
something for you and i missed like two
steps
and i just basically just like rolled
down the stairs
and he turned around he didn't bother to
help me
and he was like he just walked away you
know that's
these little traumas are like why we're
on this podcast and not normal
like these are on the spectrum no these
things that seem like oh it just
was a little thing but they [ __ ] you up
forever that's why you have to work on
yourself because
those little things happen all day every
day and it's just like
those boys were doing that for whatever
weird little
thing they were working out too yeah of
course yeah and girls here they shave
their legs at what middle school
when do you start shaving your legs and
i didn't know that that was a thing so
i'd wear shorts to school
and i remember this dude in english
class he was like ew what the [ __ ]
he's like why are you showing that i was
like what do you mean he's like shave
that [ __ ] girl
i was like why i only shaved for swim
meets
yeah i'd be like i'm gonna show you my
body trim some time off my
i um i just remembered getting bullied
in middle school okay so there were
i our desks were like across from each
other like they were in little like
sections
and i there was this girl michelle
weintraub who was very nice there was
she was an innocent bystander in this
she was across from me on the desk
and there was a note getting passed
around behind the teacher's back and and
everyone was laughing hysterically at it
right it gets to me
and it's a picture of me with a dick oh
it goes like aunt like arrow pointing
and there's like a penis
and i i mean i hulked like i like got up
and i was already bigger than everyone
okay
i'm poor michelle if you're watching i'm
so sorry you're married with children i
know you're doing good
i stood up and i pushed that [ __ ] like
she might have gone out of the window
like she is so lucky like i just
remember her going
oh and then she had to get up i couldn't
i was like
and i like ran into the bathroom and my
teacher mr robo like chase me she's like
they're [ __ ]
they're just [ __ ] and then that's
never good when the teacher's like
comforting you i know just they're
making it worse
well you know i got a little extra
comfort in high school
i got followed under the bathroom in
high school
but it was i remember being so mad and
then
we had to have like a meeting with the
with the disciplinarian of the school
and
the the reason the kid gave that he was
mad at me was because
i had said that his friend or his sister
was hanging out with a guy that i
knew was a druggie and he's like you
called my sister a druggie
and i was like no i called that guy mike
she was hanging out with a druggie it
was like that type of thing
oh i love middle school drama druggies
for me all my drama was
on the stage it's also still middle
school drama
it's like every fight we get him we
could be 12 years old
[Laughter]
that's cool since this is a very special
island episode
um annie you mentioned that you have a
lot you have
beef with turtles right in the past
episode you're like [ __ ] turtles i'm
team straws
what is it about turtles that you have a
personal beef with
well when i graduated high school at 16
because i was molested by my teacher and
they all of a sudden were like good grad
you
congratulations you graduated um i
had this year when i was like 16 to 17
where i was like i'm not going to
college yet so instead i did these
service work trips so one i went to
hawaii to honolulu and i did the dolphin
training i think i told you guys well
you were a dolphin trainer
just like i worked with a program where
they trained dolphins and i like learned
about echolocation and
did some stuff with them for a month it
was like everyone was so old and i was
just like 17
like hey i was hanging out with like a
british bobby this woman who's
a cop in london it was just so weird but
all the dolphins are dead i didn't talk
about this no you've never talked about
that dolphins
are dead they kill themselves they
commit suicide because that's not what
they do when they're depressed
and yes and closed are you serious yeah
i think like flipper committed suicide
one died yeah how do they commit suicide
they just they go to the bottom and they
don't come up for air because they have
a blowhole so occasionally they have to
come up right
so you should name this podcast blowhole
but
dolphins commit suicide out of
depression they have they have a melon
they have a very very complex set of
thinking very very bright yeah the whole
thing the whole
uh research that they were doing was at
the university of hawaii and they
so they have these like fatty melons
which is where like their their blowhole
is
why what's a cetaceans with melons like
dolphins whales
tend to have um more intelligence i
guess
cetaceans that's what they are oh god
she's so smart
i did the whole program i [ __ ]
remember any of that [ __ ] but they would
like so echolocation is how they they
sort of like send out like a radar to
understand shapes and stuff
so we would cover their eyes and then
have different
um shapes that were quite similar in
these pipes and put them down and then
they would have to
match it with the one we showed them and
they would usually get it right
and feed them a fish i knew how to like
make them do different this was kiss
and they could make them kiss each other
back flip
like they could do a bunch of stuff but
will you make us kiss each other
it's not that hard we're all just kind
of waiting for it as dave said in the
last episode this is something different
this is not really a podcast it's
something else but um it was like a big
it was fun really working with mike
phoenix the best i remember like
on her rostrum's the back right dorsal
fins were here
her rostrum had like this little notch
and i wanted i'm so glad i never got a
tattoo because
you know i'd have a dolphin deal in my
[ __ ] [ __ ] stand
because my wheelchair would have a whale
i'm so surprised
of all people that you don't have a tram
stamp i had to i got piercings i was
saved by
a [ __ ] uh piercing gun i was saying
you have no tattoos zero tattoos that is
unbelievable to me annie this is a mind
and i lost my regenerate on a water bed
in northeast philadelphia when i was 14
years old with dmx
blasting and i do not have a [ __ ] stamp
i have a [ __ ] stamp
it matches angelina jolie's dragon on
her arm before she covered it up
because that's how like that's i just
wanted a tattoo picked one off the wall
i was in vegas
got 16 and i was like i'm gonna be the
only high schooler with a tattoo and i
got it on my back and then
boy do i regret it shout out to [ __ ]
joe though that's his name he did it
tattoo
i i'm so glad you didn't get it to be
like angelina jolie and then she got
hers removed
i would have done that i love her she's
so pretty you should get her
um billy bob on your own tattooed on
your face
oh my god get billy bob get billy bob
esther what is hello fresh hey annie
well with hellofresh you get
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
hello fresh cuts out stressful meal
planning and grocery store trips so you
can enjoy cooking and get dinner on the
table in about 30 minutes or less
try meals ready in 20 minutes or less
lightening prep recipes and quick
breakfasts and lunches perfect for your
busy schedule
i love this because i can pretend i cook
when i do this i go i'm a chef
and it's 30 sec it's 30 minutes it takes
no time
it tastes delicious way better than
anything i would have made in my own can
i tell you the two facts that sold me on
hellofresh one is that they have been
named
newsweek's most trusted meal kit company
of 2021 with over four million household
serves
and served and it's better value
you guys hello fresh is actually 28
cheaper
than shopping at your local grocery
store and 72 cheaper than a restaurant
meal without sacrificing the quality
that to me it's like you're saving money
you feel good about yourself because you
make the food yourself
and the ingredients are all there for
you it's easy
go to hellofresh.com bloodbath12
that's bloodbath12 and use
codebloodbath12 for 12 free meals
including free shipping
so you guys can go to hellofresh.com
bloodbath12 and use code bloodbath12 and
those are the numbers one
two for 12 free meals including free
shipping so all you have to do is use
code bloodbath
the number one the number two
bloodbath12 for 12 free meals you guys
we love hellofresh we know you will too
okay so we all know
that we should drink more water right
but by the time you feel
thirsty it's too late you're already
dehydrated and you can't focus and you
feel
tired your lips are peeling and bleeding
you can keep feeling your best though by
maximizing your hydration correct
did you know that hydration can be tied
to improved mood better focus
and mental clarity more energy clear
skin and more
that's why the girls in our show we use
hydrant hydrant is a refreshing drink
mix powder made
with four key electrolytes sodium
potassium magnesium and zinc it's made
with real fruit juice powder and no
artificial sweeteners or synthetic
colors
no nonsense all science hydrant sleep
is a new bedtime mix carefully
formulated
to promote restful sleep and hydration
hydrant sleep includes melatonin
magnesium l-theanine gaba and chamomile
to promote
restful high quality sleep these
products i have to say rule and i was
really dumb about this like i didn't
know
i thought you wanted to straight up
water but you actually want
this kind of blend of electrolytes to
truly make you feel hydrated
and it's backed by a 100 satisfaction
guarantee if you don't love it
send it back for a full refund we've got
a special deal for our listeners by the
way
to save you 20 off your first order or
subscribe and save 30
on your first subscription order go to
drink hydrant.com
bathgirls or enter our promo code
bathgirls at checkout that's
dot d-r-i-n-k-h-y-d-r-a-n-t.com slash
bathgirls and enter our promo code
bathgirls for 20
off your first order drink hydrant.com
bathgirls and enter promo code bathgirls
to save 20
and we thank them for sponsoring this
podcast hydrant
where water meets wellness
is jaws possible um so
let me tell you a real a story you might
really hate the largest shark carnage in
history actually happened in the
philippines
and it was in world war ii um i don't
remember the name of the vessel
but hundreds of sailors
got ate up no
it was a blood soup no they fell the
shakes the ship
sank and it was shark infested waters
and it turned into
you know like sharks they they like chum
and
um hundreds of people how many people
was it george
uh looks like 75 uss indianapolis uss
indianapolis
but for shark to hunt us no i that's
impossible
sharks are actually really really i've
swam with sharks what i was outside of a
cage i swam with galapagos
how is that safe it is safe because
there's a way
for sharks to determine whether or not
your prey
or just another apex predator in the
water like if you're flapping around
like
a fish in need they're going to
see you as a fish
a weekend fish and they're going to come
for you they treat you like i treat you
esther
but if you're just confident they're not
going to eat you yeah so there's a way
we were told when we swam
um when we did the when we swam with
sharks that it's like
you stay on top of them because there's
a hierarchy and in that shark hierarchy
the the smaller sharks stay at the
bottom and the bigger sharks stay up top
and when you see a shark look it
straight in the eye
so it knows it's it's not threatened by
you it doesn't seem like
a pretty kid from middle school would
really have some trouble huh
so when you're swimming with sharks
you're doing this constantly i'm in the
water i'm looking
i'm looking i'm always looking around me
it's like a race
like dominance no but then i think
you're crazy how are you
no no no because i honestly think like
sharks anytime they take a bite out of a
human they don't eat that meat
it's all by accident are you serious yes
it's never
they take a chomp they take a bite
they're like oh [ __ ] this is horrible
and then the person bleeds to death but
it's never like the shark ate the leg
yeah they don't usually eat the whole
person right
they never eat the whole person sharks
are so misrepresented
they don't swallow they spit good sharks
oh wait no people like her i promise you
will you go
shark diving with me are you cringe that
would be nice
this is what you would have to do if we
go to hawaii this is all i would ask of
you
is that you hang on to the side of the
boat you wear a mask and snorkel
and then you look down and i promise
okay nothing will happen to you there
will be about 30 40 sharks around you
usually galapagos um some uh other reef
sharks an occasional tiger shark
but it nothing will happen to you do
normal people do this normal people do
it all the time in fact the girl that
the last time i did it i went with a
girl who was a really poor swimmer but
her boyfriend dragged her into it she
was frightened
but she did it anyway and she got out of
there feeling like a [ __ ]
like the baddest [ __ ] on earth she's
like oh my god i had it wrong the whole
time
what if your whole personality changed
okay i'll do it
i i beg you it will change your life
let's go now
she's like i'll do it if we do it in the
next 24 hours
shout out to ocean ramsay that's who
leads that's her
i can't wait that sounds so fun to watch
esther get eaten by sharks i mean
to watch esther enjoy uh
crossing something off her bucket list
guys i was watching jaws i was banging
this guy
watching jaws and i got my period
what and i forgot to say it last time
we brought up jaws it was unbelievable
that reminds me
i once hooked up with a guy and we were
watching that
matthew mcconaughey movie where it's in
a swamp like i think it's called mud
yeah mud yeah and i remember we were
about to hook up he pulled his pants
down and i had never seen a bigger penis
in my life
but the one thing that i i drove home
crying
i never even hooked up with your pants
the dick was hooked
down oh yeah i've never seen anything
like that
penis and i literally this these are the
words that came out of my mouth i was
like i think you're so hot i just don't
know what to do with that and i ran out
the door and i drove home
are you like i don't know what to do
with that like i think that might
actually like
take out my pancreas the only way that
could have a better story is if you said
and i ran out and had jules drive me
home
i'm bobby or bobby drake you've never
seen an underhook i this is the only
issue with the hooks is
if you're if you find a hook match
because you know all of our like
right i might [ __ ] tilts to the side
right yeah i have a size how do you know
because my gynecologist told me she's
like oh you have a tilted uterus which
is no i think it's like
yeah it's very normal like 20 of women
have it but i definitely have like my
like g-spot is on a specific side and
stuff so there's certain dicks that are
your universe is backwards right yeah
it's inside out someone flipped it and
put my books in it
well that's like when babies are born
with um their intestines outside of
their bodies what no that's way
sadder than what we were talking about i
was just making a call back to the
middle school thing we don't have to
talk about it
it's not that's not like that it's
called gastroschisis it's really simple
they survive yes it's actually yes very
survivable
and he just killed them off i just
stabbed it right away i didn't know it's
part of the series
okay sorry reverse uterus and hook
penises continue yeah no i'm just saying
sometimes you get one at the right angle
but if it's
raw and wrong angle it's bad yeah tear
you up
it's really bad it's like you get ripped
from side to side like the joker
i it just look i'm all for the mild
your face is very surprising have you
always just had straight
arrow penises i think so like i don't
know what you guys are referring to and
i can't picture it like this esther a
really big dick that's curved this way
the head is almost like
i can't picture how that would even get
inside and when it hooked
my this guy was hot hooked i've seen one
that looks like a harry potter scar
i thought i had to [ __ ] him upside down
i'm like all right we're gonna need to
get a strap coming from the ceiling
but i don't want to jewels they don't
lower me
i want to make sure that we're not penis
shaming i'm not
look i like i literally i'm just saying
there's they like it's like a fit
a size fit like you can get the right
correct because i talked to his best
friend
two weeks ago and i was like hey
remember so and so
i was like did he tell you that i ran
away from it from his penis
and he was like oh yeah like that's uh
that's something that's like
something that happens a lot in his life
because it was
massive yeah sometimes you just you were
like i wasn't expecting to hurt
yeah i just wasn't down for the
experience at the time now that i think
about it
i like missed an opportunity to no you
definitely could have done like a really
like good core
exercise where you kind of like flip
your legs up and
under you really could have had some
experimenting there
do you ever watch a porn and then the
guy's dick is so big that it's like
you can't even watch it you're just like
ow like you could see how hard that
would hurt i am not a size queen
i will never be a size queen it's not my
thing i like very average size sticks
very average and i'm talking like five
and a quarter
is perfect for me six max anything over
it's just not for me i'm down with
average if you do have a micro penis
it's
it's fine it's just you better be eating
me out for breakfast
like i hooked up with this guy who had a
he definitely had like a micro like
there was like a issue
like it was very small but he i mean
that boy could eat plus like a
really yeah that's what i'm saying he
always had like he i always noticed he
had
uh long-term girlfriends because i think
i do think like cunnilingus is
a lot more of a relationshipy thing than
like you're not just going out to the
clubs and just
eating girls some guys are some guys are
down for that but
some guys are like but he just i think
he didn't want to go through the trauma
of like
showing his because i was it was really
wild i do imagine that that's how you
get good at it
is having a like a long-term girlfriend
yeah but i think he also just didn't
want to like deal with
i will agree guys who have a lot of
one-night stands are never good in bed
men who've been in long-term
relationships always the best
yeah especially when they're just coming
off a breakup and then now they get to
like
you know give you all they've learned
this like five years worth of skills
but also it's like it's such a like
grown-up thing to be able to communicate
sexually with
yeah yeah i just remember how many times
like in my 20s
like everything it was so bad and i was
like oh when is it over and i would
never fake my
i faked my orgasm one time and the guy
[ __ ] called me it was so annoying he
was fingering me
it was my friends we lived in santa fe
in albuquerque's like an hour away and
it's like
the city near there so we're like let's
go to albuquerque and my friend's like i
have all these friends from college
so her friend was and he was like fine i
was drunk it's like it was just like
sure we'll hook up
he was like had read our body ourselves
or something recently and he was just
trying to be so
like mansplaining about his like [ __ ]
fingering and he was like
no yeah just you could you feel like you
have to pee but i'm like no
[ __ ] i have to pee i just did like five
shots of jaeger like a piss jaeger all
over you
and he was like finger man's nails were
just like me i was like dude call me in
two weeks and let me know if i have hpv
and then any like he's like go and it
was like hurting so bad and he was so
sure he was going to make me like squirt
myself into the next room
i hate that and it was so annoying and
this was like before i even knew what
squirting i was like in
college you know this was in the 1970s
and um
and he i just like faked an orgasm he
was like that wasn't real and i was like
all right good night
see ya i never fake him like i faked in
high school
and have i told you guys this in high
school
my high school sweetheart dumped me and
i
was just a wreck and so i remember one
day like he
i kept calling him and he kept hanging
up on me and i kept calling him like
like five times and then finally i call
him and i'm like i faked every orgasm
and i hung up
and the phone rang and i was like
oh that's power and he was like are you
serious and i was like yeah
and i finally like got his attention and
he was destroyed by that and i couldn't
i was like wow i didn't think a guy
would care about that
but after that i never ever faked again
because that just feels like
why am i exactly why would i yes
give you the compliment when you didn't
earn it and they'll never get better
it's like you're doing such a disservice
to the future women
and then they're gonna go around
thinking that they they got it and it's
like i don't that's
everybody hurts in that situation in
when it comes to sex
meritocracy is everything you got to
earn your [ __ ]
i'm not going to give you anything for
free especially
when she comes out and by the way um
i got this you guys have been calling me
a gold digger but the truth
do we want to finish um your uh story
with the turtle so [ __ ] sorry guys no
that sounds
crazy anyway so i did hawaii then we
went to i did
a trip in central america we went to
guatemala belize costa rica and honduras
and in guatemala i had the most fun but
i fell off a horse
so this is two weeks into a three-month
backpacking trip
i fell off a horse did you get right
back on oh that's what they say
to do i think i had to be carried on a
horse
on my stomach because my back
was raw esther
i mean it was i bruised but you would
have actually really enjoyed this
it was like raw pus back
and i bruised ribs like i had to go to
like the hospital
in guatemala and they didn't speak any
english and they kept
i'm on the x-ray table and they have me
like my bear
[ __ ] back on this table and they keep
moving me and they're just
moving me and like scraping it against
it and i'm like
screaming and they're like um and he
kept going no breach
no breach and i'm like i was born
breached yes what
and he goes no breach and i'm like what
are you saying and finally really he
said don't breathe so it was like a 45
minute thing that could have been two
minutes
because i kept breathing during the
x-ray anyway so i
had bruised these bones i luckily it was
in a [ __ ] central america so i was
able to just buy all of these like
i got great drugs yeah drugs for it but
i was 17.
everyone had to carry they [ __ ] hated
me everyone had to carry my stuff for me
you would have been so proud of me and
um
so we went to do the sea turtle project
where you had to
dress up in all black and have this like
red
gel thing over your flashlight and you
had to go out in the middle of the night
and like stalk the beaches for a big
leatherback sea turtle to come up
to lay its [ __ ] nasty [ __ ] juice
eggs
let me tell you so they come up and
they're in a trance so they don't
like if unless you're like bright lights
in their face they don't see you
and they dig these holes with their
little fin things
and then they just drop this goo and
eggs down and you have to
get under with the [ __ ] bag and
you're just smelling the [ __ ]
oh you're catching these nasty ass eggs
and then you go back to the hatchery of
like hatchery duty which by the way i'm
[ __ ] costa rica people poachers make
like 200
an egg or something it was like
something crazy so i'm watching like
thousands of dollars worth of eggs in
this hatchery
by myself and i just remember i was sick
i'd eaten a bad coconut and there was
like
just the empty bag with all the [ __ ]
juice like i could smell it i'm just
so disgusted and i just they used to set
they sell
sold these like little like leatherback
sea turtle necklaces and i wanted to
make one that had an egg with like a
bite out of it because i was like i'm
team poacher we gotta get rid of these
[ __ ]
they're like oh and they cry like black
it was just
speaking of poachers if we were all in
an archaeological like excavation site
and we were on like a dig
if you found what you knew to be let's
say
an 18 million dollar sought after
treasure
would you tell your other excavators or
slide it under your sleeve and take it
for yourself
i'm thinking honestly the safest thing
to do
is to like let everyone know if it's
people you trust
so that you can all work together to
like safely start to be dead so fast
but but yeah no i know i
i want to work on a joke where about how
i know that if i wasn't involved in a
bank robbery i'd be the person that gets
shot right after we get the money
like well what would you be what would
your service be in the bank robbery
though
like what part are you to stick them up
person are you the stigma
she's definitely not the driver because
there's too much trash on her car
no but that's a really interesting
question because it's like what's the
safest smartest thing
because maybe keeping it to yourself is
the safest
but if if i was there with you guys i'd
be like okay we have this now we need to
get the [ __ ] out we'd have to split it
with you know
that's the same thing what about my cut
and we're like get out of your nerves
no that's the question it's like do you
take it for yourself
sell it on the black market because you
know at the very least you'd get a 10
million dollar cut
or give it to the your the museum
and do like the protocol or whatever and
then get
like 200 000 the museum would have to
give us a reward but i
this is what okay this is what i learned
from johnny bananas on
the challenge shout out i love him
sometimes they
at the end of the challenge they'll like
be teams and they win but the person
in the partnership that had the fastest
time gets a choice to be like do you
want to keep this like
500 thousand dollars or million dollars
for yourself or do you want to split it
with your partner
and he said he wanted to keep it for
himself and a lot of people were mad at
him but i was like [ __ ] yeah dude
because
he decided he said that friendship was
not it was like how much is that
friendship worth is it worth this amount
of money
that's true so it would really depend
for me how much i like the people around
me like if i was digging with you guys
i'd be like yeah let's all get like our
two million dollars split if it was some
[ __ ] that'd been nagging me for nine
days and
i was forced to bunk with and i don't
know i just hate her
i thought you just said you'd share it
with me
i'm sharing everything forced to bunk
with as i said
in a car in the back seat she was like i
don't want to sleep in bobby's car
you're just
shoving her head into the [ __ ] car
um uh this is a great segway actually
for a question we have from jonathan
okay hi bloodbath girls i have a weird
question for you
if you three were to rob a bank what
role would each of you take in the
robbery
one of you has to be the driver one has
to be the muscle
and one has to be the lock picker all
right thanks
esther's very good at picking her nose
so i think okay is for her
i have really sweaty hands so i'm out
the lock picking game i'm not a very
good driver
i'm gonna muscle you're obvious to the
muscle and i'm the driver what's the
muscle do
i'm the stick em up girl i'm the one who
runs gets the money i'm the one who
does what's the muscle ask your [ __ ]
trainer okay
and what does the lock picker do though
are you the safe the safe
you pick the law oh yeah okay i have
tiny hands i'll watch a few youtube
videos and figure out how to do that
she doesn't even need tools she just
uses her little fingers together i
am with my long like long nails like
okay i got that i feel like you'd be
very good at that and we don't have to
worry about her messing up her manicure
because her manicure messes up her
manicure
i'm going to assume annie you're the
best driver out of all of us three years
but i still think i am a better driver
i'm the fastest driver you're the
fastest because i'm a grandma driver i
follow the rules i don't
you know i always put my turn signal on
nah [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] i'll take some snort some
adder i'll be ready for you oh my god if
annie's driving we're gonna end up in
the ocean
and you get hit by sharks finally with a
big bag of money
oh that's how we go out guys i love that
with elma and louise we drive off a
cliff accidentally rich but
i [ __ ] knew it i knew you shouldn't
be a part of
you shouldn't be the driver i knew i was
gonna eventually die by your handbag we
gave you too big of a roll
i'm like it should have been called
bitchbee
[Laughter]
[Music]
i cannot believe that just happened
that's crazy
but i'm glad he gave his options of what
yeah because we would have been all over
the place
i feel like that's the one thing we've
the fastest we've ever agreed on
something
well we had to pick muscle drivers we
had an open mic of it
no because we're all so [ __ ]
different
that like it can we'll never each be the
same of something you know like we'll
never be the same spice girl we're all
always so different
i'm posh i think we thought about this
oh yes we're both ginger oh [ __ ] never
mind
wait so you guys are not i definitely
don't feel like my essence is ginger
so i'm gonna go ahead and say that i'm
not sporty i'm scary i'm probably baby
real sticky yeah you're obviously baby
no but i but baby's really like baby's
good
baby's great and she's one of the only
ones that can really sing but i really
do
i think you are a ginger thank you i
think you got the sass in you
thanks you're posh yeah jinger's a
little boss you're first of all
here i want to be the headline here is
that you're not posh no not gosh i get
to be posh already
there's absolutely nothing
[Laughter]
listen we get it i'm sporty i'm also
stephanie on baywatch we get what i am
i know it okay banana break do you
realize that stephanie had the best body
on baywatch
yes kalyla but did she she did guys they
just always put her in like
short hair unflattering stuff guys let's
have a banana break yes let's go banana
[Music]
esther's mad she's not posh no i don't
want to be
posh but you're not posh no i'm posh
we don't have a posh i said it and it's
too late george's posh are we going it's
mayor george
are we gonna do a spice girls um episode
then yeah
oh we gotta get those shoes then we also
have forms at least with the that part
i feel like esther and i already own
platforms no i had geriatric like
i did but my dog my old dog ate them
want to she's so um that is really oh my
god what is this
is this was this just for me well you
can share if you want what is it so i
gave you the option
you don't have to there's there is pork
in one of the pieces did you go here
what is it it's just it's just some
pastries do you know what they are
[Music]
for the blueberry oh my god i have a
guava yes
i would have loved it if you're like i
don't like guava
i love the guava cheese from porto's oh
my god
wow which one's that esther it's the
blueberry special you have to eat it
like it's like
body part oh it's the pastry flakiness
is very impressive how do i share
will you come get one i'll eat it later
oh
it's not a good look
i'll stick with my massive rotten banana
thank you
[Laughter]
yourself esther's things get better ours
get worse
i mean there's no way anyone we're going
to make all three happy it looks like
someone sat
on this banana well esther was trying to
learn how to kegel
she looks like she's on that drug flakka
okay you guys um i am going to introduce
some
hawaiian treats sent to us
by my friend who's a chef in hawaii his
name is aaron matson
and he he sent us all of these fancy
treats
so you get to choose one this in
particular is my favorite
it's li-mui and it's like dried plums in
like a sort of
tart sour powder um
esther there's ahi jerky
[Music]
um there's hurricane popcorn mochi
crunch and nori so seaweed
oh wow i'm always game for some sort of
popcorn
there's li hing muy mango and then
there is a macadamia oh my god it's mad
matcha chocolate are you guys into
matcha
i want the plums okay here or
you like sour stuff yeah okay this is
sour
if you don't like it you never have to
eat it again super ingredients plum
sugar
okay she doesn't trust she's been
traumatized
you ready one two three
they're not that sour it's really
really weird you guys tower when you got
in
it's like weird it's like weird
are you looking at yourself in the
[ __ ] mirror [ __ ] it tastes like
like which is so i don't know there's
like
like a duty tastes mm-hmm no duty wait
is this tamarind or plum
plum it's plum right there's a little
salt in it
it's so sweet and so salty
it's like our podcast oh like my whole
mouth is
coated shout out to lihimoi oh yeah
thank you sorry i love it
this one is mochi crunch and nori
hawaiian
popcorn oh it smells so good
wow this one i feel like you'd like
esther i don't know if i can smell it
first i think you'd like it
okay yeah
it's good it's not nasty mm-hmm
i think i prefer
it's actually pretty good mm-hmm i
could be addicted to that actually
it's good the nori at first i was like
oh it tastes like seaweed but
because it is seaweed but it doesn't
bother me i do never eat seaweed packs
of snacks
i have but they just they're it's like
cotton candy disappears so fast oh my
god
carlos eats them like that's his meal
carlos is
really losing a lot of weight anorexic
it's not funny but we gotta laugh at it
um what's the final thing george
matcha chocolate i mean this it's like
you can't go wrong with matcha chocolate
in my eyes
matcha makes me throw up really yeah
like it actually does
matcha and spirulina whenever i drink
something with those i hate spirulina
it makes me sick matcha is not spiritual
i like matcha a lot though
thank you aaron thank you kalyla's
friend
next time we get a fresh pineapple
george can you hand me just one more
masubi can i have another one too
oh thank you or where are we out with
names
no idea oh so thank you for listening
thank you for supporting
whatever it is that we are and make sure
you
like this video subscribe on youtube and
write us a review on itunes why not look
at annie she's wearing a [ __ ]
she's not she's not dressed i'm
undressed and unwell
she's earned it okay i want a goddamn
review
bye guys thank you
you